SPEAKER: So this
demo is about showing
how Kubeflow and
Kubernetics together
can make machine learning really
easy, scalable, and portable.
So this demo is about the
operational efficiency
that you gain by adopting
Kubernetics and Kubeflow.
So the sample use case
we have taken here
is that of predicting sentiments
associated with reviews.
And so here's a very
simple dev app, right?
Let's go over some of the
reviews that are sample
reviews that are listed here.
First one says, "It's
a typical McDonald's.
Food was typical.
Employees were typical."
Everything is typical.
So there's really nothing
positive about this review.
And so we would expect it
to be a negative review.
You don't want to highlight
it on your restaurant website
as one of the premier reviews.
And the second one
here, it says it's good.
"The service is good.
Overall, they do a good job."
So this seems to be a
pretty positive review,
so we should probably
be highlighting that.
Whereas on the
right side here, it
says, "Really excited to hear
of this restaurant coming
to Toronto," and
so on and so on.
"The service here is not great."
So it's not a review that
you want to highlight.
So it's probably
a negative review.
So what would you expect--
let's say you throw this
task at your engineer,
and then your
engineer just builds
something, some back-end
system, to classify
them as positive or negative.
Let's see what the
engineers built.
Turns out, what the
engineer has built doesn't
meet what the humans expect.
It's literally classifying
them incorrectly.
Let's go look at the code
that the engineer has used.
This is not good code.
It's really dumb code.
I don't know how
that got checked in.
But in any case, it's there.
So now let's go improve
it and let's go fix it.
So this is where machine
learning comes to the rescue.
There's quite a few
machine learning models
that you can use to solve these
sort of language problems.
And Tensor2Tensor happens to be
one really popular model that
can be used for lots of
different applications
like language modeling,
sentiment analysis,
summarization, and so on.
And so sentiment analysis is
one application for this model.
So what we're
going to do now is,
we're going to use Kubeflow.
We're going to use this
Tensor2Tensor preexisting model
and we're going to
operationalize that.
We're going to train that
model using public data that's
provided by year.
And then what we're
going to do is,
we're going to deploy that
model to a Kubernetics cluster
and then see if I
can improve this web
app to become smarter and make
the right kind of predictions.
So at this point, I'm going
to switch to my terminal
here where I'm going
to run the demo.
So the first stage of
the demo is that I'm
going to switch to Minikube.
Then what I'm
going to do is, I'm
going to deploy Kubeflow to
my local Minikube cluster.
Kubeflow prepackaged
with a few components.
I'm going to show you
what components exist.
And you're also going to
see that Kubeflow extracts
out a lot of different
Kubernetics constructs
that you have to put together
in order to build applications
that data scientists and ML
practitioners can consume.
They find it really hard to
consume Kubernetics directly.
So Kubeflow acts as the glue
between the apps that data
scientists like and the
infrastructure efficiency
that Kubernetics provides you.
So I'm switching to my
local Minikube context here.
The next thing that
I'm going to do
is, I'm going to deploy
Kubeflow locally.
So it's as simple as
running one simple command.
Then the next
thing is, I'm going
to show Jupyter Notebooks.
So this is part of Kubeflow,
that you have Jupyter Notebooks
that are built in.
So you can go in and log in
and create your own Notebooks.
There are many
pre-canned images.
And you can choose
different CPU.
You can choose different memory.
And then you can also choose
GPUs if you happen to have it.
But Minikube doesn't
support it yet,
so you probably can't
use GPUs locally.
But you get a pretty good
set of configurations,
and you can bring
your own images.
So what this provides is, it
provides you a local Notebook
environment through which you
can iterate locally and build
models interactively, locally.
But we're not going
to use Notebooks now.
Instead, what we're going to
do is, we're going to go back
and we're going to
continue training
our model using command line.
And specifically what
we're going to do is,
we're going to use a
Tf job operator that's
packaged as part of Kubeflow.
The Tf job operator lets
you do distributed training
and single-load training in
a really easy, portable way.
So similar to how you
define a deployment or a job
in Kubernetics, you can define a
TensorFlow job using the Tf job
operator.
And then the
TensorFlow job, what
it does is takes your
TensorFlow application
package as containers
and sets up
the runtime environment that
TensorFlow needs in order
to make it work in a distributed
setting and in a local setting,
and extracts all of that.
So I'm going to
configure my TensorFlow
model to run locally.
I've set the data to be
available as locally,
and I've set local
training to be true.
And the model is now deployed.
I'm going to check if the
training jobs are running.
They seem to be running.
Then the next thing
is I'm going to check
if the model is actually
running by looking at the logs.
OK, looks like the
model is running.
But I'm going to stop
here with local training,
because it's going
to take a long time.
It's probably going to
take a couple of days
for local training to complete.
But the point of
training locally
is not to build a model, but
it's rather to just make sure
that my model works.
As soon as I know
my model works,
I have the cloud to the rescue.
Now I can switch to the cloud
and use elastic compute data.
And that's what we're
going to do next.
And you're going to use the same
Kubeflow framework to do that.
So I'm going to switch
to a GK cluster.
And I'm going to show
you the GK cluster
that I have pre-provisioned.
So here's a GK cluster.
This cluster has GPUs and
TPUs already attached.
So I pre-provisioned that.
It's very easy to provision GK
clusters with TPUs and GPUs.
It's literally
running two commands.
And you get late drivers and
everything pre-installed.
So I have GPUs attached here.
And TPUs are available
from all nodes.
And I also pre-provisioned
a TPU here.
And the TPU is running
TensorFlow version 1.7.
So the next thing
that I'm going to do
is, I'm going to go
back to my terminal.
I'm going to switch context
and switch to this GK cluster.
And I'm going to
deploy Kubeflow to GKE.
And once I've deployed
Kubeflow, then I'm
going to deploy my model to GKE.
So here we're deploying
Kubeflow to GKE.
The next step is, let
me deploy the model.
So I have to change the
model parameters such
that it can run in the cloud.
I've enabled GPUs for the
cloud, and also enabled
a set of data that are
created to be on GCS.
And I have also
disabled local training.
So once the model is deployed--
next off, in
addition to GPUs, you
can also use TPUs
in Google Cloud.
And now I'm going to
deploy the same model,
but this time with TPUs.
So here you go.
I've configured TPUs, a few
parameters to make the model
point at a TPU.
And then the models are now
deployed on TPUs as well.
Now we're going to wait
for the pods to be running.
So I'm going to
switch to the GK UI
and I'm going to filter
on my demo namespace.
And once I've filtered
that, I'm going
to check whether my
training pods are running.
So turns out, my training
pods are running.
You see here that you have a
distributor cluster running.
So you have two workers and a
master and a parameter server.
These are TensorFlow concepts.
Don't worry about it
if you don't know it.
And there's also a TPU
training job that's running.
So if I go into the
TPU training job--
if we go into the
TPU training job,
then you would know that the
TPU training job is running.
And then there's
the GPU job here.
And then the GPU job is running.
And you can see here the GPU
memory and GPU unitcycle are
also being shown here for you.
And the pod is running,
and you can go in here
and you can see the logs.
The training is actually
going on already,
and it's saving
checkpoints and so on.
So once we go back, then--
OK, so training is
going on, but training
is going to take quite a while.
What can we do meanwhile?
So in addition to that,
we also get Tensible.
I forgot to mention this.
You get Tensible.
That's going to help you track
the progress of your training
both locally and in the cloud.
What I've done here is, I'm
showing you Tensible graphs
based on pre-trained models
that I ran through training.
And this is what you would see.
So what you see here
is, for GPUs, you
see a training rate of
about three, roughly.
Like 2.5 steps per second.
And then in the case of
TPUs, if you scroll down,
you see a much
higher learning rate.
And so this is to give
you a rough idea of what
sort of hardware you might use.
And in any case,
Kubernetics and Kubeflow
can work with both of them.
So now that we have gone
through the training process
and now that training is
done, the next office--
we can't wait for
training to complete.
And so what we're
going to do now
is we're going to take
a pre-trained model
and deploy it to
the same GK cluster.
And then we're going to see
if our restaurant sentiment
analysis UI can perform better.
So I'm going to go ahead and
deploy a pre-trained model
locally--
I said, sorry,
into my GK cluster.
And once that model
is deployed, now I
can go back and see if
the model is running.
So I'm going to refresh.
And my model is running.
The pods are running.
So let's switch back to my UI.
So I have the UI here.
But local classification,
it did not
do well, as we would expected.
So now, let's see if it does
well with the machine learning
model.
Yay, it does well.
It's classifying the first
and the third review correctly
as being negative, and it's
classifying the second review
as being positive.
So this demo should
have shown you
how the overall pipeline
for machine learning
can be simplified with
Kubeflow and Kubernetics
together, where your
infrastructure concerns
and application
packaging concerns are
taken care of for you.
And you focus on building great
machine learning packages that
are reusable and making a plain
machine learning really, really
easy for the rest of the world.